Hey! Welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
Today, we have a special update,
because we're gonna recordit in one shot!
It's super hot!
We're gonna walk around, show you all the people,
and all the things we've been working on.
But, it might go wrong, because again it's super hot,
and the camera is probably gonna overheat?
I'm not sure.
I have a backup camera here.
People mightdo stuff we don't want them to do...
So, let's see!
I got my spoon microphone right here.
So, yeah, let's move around.
We're starting in Basekamp!
Right here in the kitchen.
And, just to show you that it's really hot,
on the thermometer it's above 40 degrees (=104°F)!
Probably, it's maybe a few degrees hotter here,
becausewe have the plastic roof.
As you might have seen in the videos.
It's really good to choose ablack roof in a hot area...
Makes it really fresh.
So, here we have the kitchen,
where we have Dorian -- our newchef!
- Hey!
What are you cooking today?
- We're making some mushroom goulash,
and some mashed potatoes.
We're gonna fry these aubergines as well!
- All right!
Now, how is it to cook in here?
Is it not toohot today?
- It is very hot, and we also have to keep one of the doors closed.
Because, the sun is shining on a really bad angle.
So, yeah, it gets quite hot in here...
- It soundsgreat to cook here...
Okay, we'll continue! Thanks!
So, next, we'll go to the pizza hut,
whereKevin is baking some bread.
Which we do twice a week!
We also bake pizza, but we alsomake bread.
Look at them!
Some of them are already done!
How's it going here, Kevin?
- I'm making bread foreveryone!
Isn't it a bit hot to bake bread now?
- Yes, but everyone needs to eat!
That's true, that's true.
How do you make sure stuff doesn't get on fire?
- Well, we spread water around the pizzaoven.
So, we make sure everything is moist.
- Cool! Sounds great!
All right!
Do you haveanything to say to your friends in Hong Kong?
- I'm coming back tomake some peso de nada!
All right!
Let's continue here to show thearea where we live.
So, here are all the vans and the tents.
This is the yellow van that we recently renovated.
Go see it in the update!
Alice is working here.
Oh! I think she's in a call or something, so we just let her work.
Let's go down there.
Here, wealso have a nice place to chill,
which has a lot of hammocks.
So, when it's hot, it's a goodplace to take a siesta.
Here we have Rita!
What are you doing here, Rita?
- Well,we're taking care of the baby!
Is it nice to have a baby here?
- It's really cool!
We all do some shifts of taking care of the baby.
Just so that the baby has a bit more diversity.
It's enjoying the microphone a lot right now!
- The baby doesn't say much, huh?
And then, the parents canalso have a bit of free time
doing other things besides parenting.
It works really nice!
- So, isthis your baby?
Not my baby.
- A community baby!
We will continue down here.
Let's go to our latest and newest toilet.
Which we built right here!
So, that's the oldtoilet we used to have,
and we recently made an upgrade to this toilet.
It has a bunch of upgrades, and Alejandro is right here!
What are you doing here, Alejandro?
- The poop bucket is pretty full,
so we have toput in a new one.
You need a hand, I see..
So, how often do you do this?
- Every day, when thebucket is full,
we have to put it there in the bucket station and put a new one.
So, we can fill it againtomorrow!
- Okay, so, this is the sewage system of Project Kamp?
Yeah, this is our lovely sewage system,
with our bucket station for the buckets!
We put them here and cover them with a lovely lid.
And then, after a week, we put them here in the Poop Palace.
- What is this?
This is the Poop Palace, where we keep all of the compost.
You can see already we have two full ones after a month.
So, we are using it a lot!
- Who's living in the Palace?
So far, noone, but it's always open, if you want to join!
- It's still available people!
All right, thanks!
So, we can go here to our unofficial route.
Wekind of have to go here now
to make one nice shot and one nice walk.
But otherwise, we wouldhave walked back.
So: this is for you, YouTube!
This area is actually what we'verecently debarked
So, from all the trees here, we took off the bark from the bottom.
Theywould die in a few years, and don't re-sprout.
But, recently, a lot of resin started to come out, which is kind of cool.
We don't know what to do with it!
It doesn't really smell verynice.
Well, not bad either...
It just doesn't really smell.
But, it feels like quite a cool material!
It's really that every tree around here is now just losing resin!
So, it would be cool to figure outwhat to do with that.
But, yeah, the main principle is that we want
to get rid of the mimosa trees here.
This is an approach that would take a few years.
But ideally, they're then really gone and don't re-sprout
This is actually where we kind of do it for!
These little oak trees -- thenative trees from around here.
We hope that they will grow.
But, currently, it's very hard forthem,
because the mimosas just take all the sun...
So, we cherish them, and hopefully one day,
these guys are the biggest trees here!
But, it's gonna take few years...
Here, we tried something else to get rid of them.
So, just to address the YouTube comments youguys all had:
''Why do you leave stumps this long?''
The main reason is that they just sprout back
In this way, it would be easier to maintain,
because we can take off all the things that popoff.
So, it doesn't become a big new tree again.
But, we're not sure it's very effective...
Maybe, choppingit down on the bottom is easier,
because then you can brush cut it.
It's an experiment, but we eitherway would
take care of this later in the year.
We still want to do it!
We'd plant a few morefruit trees,
but you can see more of that later!
Well, I hope, because that means we've done it.
All right, so, let's have a look in our office!
In our beautiful ruin, with Portuguesequality.
A solid build!
So, here we are in the office.
I'm usually not allowedto have shoes in here,
but I'll just do it for you guys, so it's faster.
So here we usually have the videoeditors.
This is Tincho!
Usually, we would have Guillerme as well,
but he's currently on holiday...
He's with us always in the background.
Isn't he, Tincho?
- He's always with us!
How is it going here?
- Very good!
I'm working on the next update about the can roof.
So, yeah, it's going well.
- A good video?
It willbe a good one, yeah!
- How is it working in the heat here?
Kind of difficult sometimes!
Thecomputer doesn't work...
There is too much heat, but we can manage it. With the mate, always...
- They're used tothe heat now!
All right, thanks!
Here, we have the other Guilherme.
What are you doing?
- I'm working on the Community Platform.
What is the Community Platform?
- So, it's a place where the online communitycan
share knowledge, how-to's and resources.
So, your coding software to make sure the
community can collaborate online?
- Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, I'm currently working on adding replies
to the research modules.
So, you guys can reply and talk to each other.
- Is it complex?
No, but itrequires a lot of work.
So, if you guys have skills and want to help out,
see the link in the description below!
Let us know that you want to help.
- Software developers: we can use your help!
Also,online and remote, you can always help out!
Thanks!
All right, so, now we go down here,
where theGeneral Help team is working.
They are chopping a lot of mimosas.
The main reason for that isthat it's
currently very hot, so the fire season is starting.
The neighbors have been telling us a lot
to chop the mimosas, but it's a lot.
But, the main important one is the road,
because it's alsoour escape from the place if it catches on fire.
How's it going here?
- Good and hot!
We're making a cleared route,
so we can easily escape when it's needed.
- An emergency exit?
Emergency exit is what we call it.
- What do you have there?
Firewood, that we are stacking up in a pile,
so we can useit for winter!
- Do you still like chopping the mimosas?
Yes, but I'm speaking for myself!
Istill like the chopping of the mimosas!
Everyone seems very happy there, so it's great!
- It's almost finishing time too...
All right! Cool!
Yeah, it's a big job.
All right!Good luck!
- Thank you! Ciao!
Ciao!
So, yeah, as you can see,
they've beenchopping all of this here.
This also used to be mimosas.
It's quite nice that it opens upthe land much more!
It would help in case of a fire,
that we can go out moresafe faster.
So, here we have the Community Center!
I'm guessing you've seen it before.
It's this big ruin.
Sadly, I don't really have a good update on this...
We cleaned it a while ago.
But, stuff isgrowing back.
We need to clean it again...
But, the main thing is that we're still in the process
of legalization and paperwork.
We're making sure we have a good drawing,
but it's a complex building...
Ithas a lot of infrastructure,
like sewage systems, electricity systems, water systems...
So, it's goingslow.
I think I hear a car coming!
I'm gonna try to wait for thisone,
because then I don't have to walk up.
I think it's Timo that has come back
from, usually, some shopping.
So, maybe we can hop in the back?
Hey Timo! How's it going?
- Hi! It's going nice!
Ijust came from shopping!
Do you want a lift?
- Yeah, can we pop in here?
Of course, but we have to find some room!
Let's go!
- That's nice here with the air conditioningon!
Yes, it's very refreshing!
- I can see that!
Do you like driving in the pickup?
- A lot, yeah!
It's like a couch!
Not necessarily in this weather,
but yeah, in general, it'scool.
- You went to get some food?
Yeah, I went to Nuno's and the Bulk Store,
and I gotsome supplies, some veggies, some old stuff...
- It's your weekly routine?
My weekly routine exactly.
- All right! Thanks!
Would you mind helping me
carrying some stuff to the storage container?
- Sure!
Which one? This guy?
- That, and maybe some more over there?
All right! Thanks for the ride!
So, here we have the storage container.
It's where we drop all our dried food.
Hey Alan!
- How's it going?
I can show you the container.
I'll just give it to you here, Timo.
- Thankyou.
Then, we can continue the tour.
But, it's great having this!
- Have a nice tour.
Thanks!
So, here'sthe more sort of landscaping area in the container.
With all the tools chainsaws and brush cutters that we work with.
What are you doing?
- Well, General Help has been hard at work,
and all of our tools need sharpening.
So, I've been working on that...
- Are you good with sharpening?
Yeah! I think you can see that the toolsare quite sharp...
I don't know if I'd say the same about myself, but...
- Okay, but your fingers are stillon,
so maybe it means they're not sharp enough...
Exactly, exactly.
There could be uh some more work in here
Cool! All right.
Well, good luck with that!
Adrian I think used to behere as well?
Hey Adrian!
- What's up Dave?
Good, you?
- Good! I'm working on by digester, but...
Go away, go away!
No spoilers, nospoilers!
That's for later!
- That's for later, when we're setting up a biogas system.
For later...
Okay, let's see more stuff!
Now,we have the workspace to go to.
We're currently back in Basekamp!
This is where we started originally.
Here we have Jaime, who is doing some stuff.
I don't know...
Let's see what he's doing.
Hey Jaime!
- Hello!
I'm tryingto find drill bits.
One specific drill bit, like everything is a bit a mess around here...
- How come?
A lot of people are using the tools,
and all the stuff we have in here.
Not everybody comes back with it,
oreverything comes back at the same time.
So, yeah, I'm looking...
- A community workspace, huh?
A community workspace, yeah...
- Cool, andhow is it in the heat in this black box?
I mean, I'm not spending a lot of time in here, but it's hot!
It's really hot!
Just come here for tools, and get out of here.
- Yeah, it's basically abig toolbox now.
A big metal box.
- Cool! All right!
And the rest of the guys are inthe pig trailer?
- Yep, downstairs.
Cool, then, well, let's have a look at that!
Good luck findingyour tool!
Sounds fun...
So, now, we can go to the pig trailer,
which we recently bought thanksto our Patreons!
It's down here.
It's not a very official path here...
This is next toour well, where we get our water.
We recently did a small update actually!
We installed the sensorthat can measure
the height of the water level.
It's to see, especially in these hot days,
if the water level goes down or up.
So, we can keep track of it, to make sure it's not empty.
But,you can see more of that in the research module!
So, let's continue here on this path.
A small update also...
A kind of a big one!
Just this week, we finally bought this middlepiece of land!
It was originally not ours,
and we made a video about that a few weeks ago.
It had a lot of views actually, which is cool.
It was kind of weird that the middle land was not from us...
But now, we've been talking with the neighbor,
and now we finally bought it!
Now,we are on our land, and not on the neighbors land anymore!
So, the pig trailer is around here.
Youhave to go through this little maze...
We made this pathway to also get electricity,
because wedon't have any there...
But, we needed to work on the pig trailer,
and to be able to use the tools we have,
We kind of need electricity...
This was chopped not too long ago,
but stuffalways grows back here very fast!
As you can see here, there are a lot of brambles
There she is: the pig trailer!
We have to go down here on this wall.
We don't really have a properstairs yet...
So, I hope that's gonna be okay.
It's maybe also a good moment,
where you can guys see a sweatyvideo maker!
This is Javi right here!
- Moving on!
Thank you, Dave.
- Alright-y!
All is okay!
- All right!
So, the pig trailer.
We're hard at work trying to convert this
into a little house to live in.
We have set up a littleworkstation here, where we can work.
It's just so we don't have to walk to
the workspace each timewith some tools...
How's it going here?
- It's going all right!
Whatcha making?
- I'm making a nice frame for the door.
I got some old door posts here.
I'm gonnamake a nice frame, and then we put it in here!
Then, the door is open for you to enter the house.
- Cool! Canwe have a look inside?
Yes!
Watch your steps!
- I will...
So, yeah, here's a preview of the house.
There'sgoing to be living room and a bedroom.
It still requires imagination,
but maybe we will also put a roof ontop.
Probably...
Isn't it hard to work in the heat here?
- It's okay with some shade!
A really nice tarp with a cool breeze with a t-shirt contest.
- All right! You don't seem to struggle with it!
Cool! Well, goodluck!
Here we have Robert!
He's from Iceland and he's always wearing a lot of clothes!
I don't know how he does that.
What's your secret?
- Don't think about it.
''Don't think about it.''
Cool!I'll keep that in mind for next time.
Good luck!
So, now, we need to go kind of far away on the land.
We also build a few things there,
because most of the time we spend here.
It's quite central and it's allin one place.
We're trying to keep all the infrastructure
together and the people together.
So, it's a biteasier to manage, but also for fire.
Now, we're going to go to more the lower part of the land
It's a bit further away with a bit of different
vegetation as well, which is cool!
But, it's gonna be quite a walk...
We're currently walking on a new road we made!
Maybe you can see it when I walk here?
It's a big rough road straight through the mimosas,
but itwas needed to deliver the pig trailer to the land.
Well, yeah, we still need to make this
more nicer and proper a bit...
But, yeah, we will make it good.
Now, I'm just trying to fill up thetime
basically before we get there...
So, I thought maybe I can tell you a joke,
but I don't really have one...
maybe you have a joke!
leave jokes in the comments if you have one I can use
it next time
but instead of me talking
Can we can speed it up?
You don't have to listen to this, and you can just sit back.
We'll walk to the lower part of the land,
andwe'll meet you there again!
So, let's speed it up!
All right, so, here we are at the bottom of theland.
There used to be a pathway here, but we don't come here often!
So, as you can see,it gets a bit adventurous to go through here.
Every time, we have to go a littlebit lower.
It keeps us flexible!
But, this is the part where we found
an oldwell from the neighbors.
It's right here!
It's quite impressive.
In the winter time,it was really almost until the edge full of water.
Now, it's very low...
I can throw in somethingjust for you guys,
so you can see how deep it is.
It was only a little bit of water rightnow.
But, yeah, it's also hot and the middle of the summer...
It's nice to keep an eye on the water levels like this one.
Let's continue here.
This is where we have our big grass field!
A big patchthe bottom of the land, and close to the creek.
This is where we potentially have a Project Kamp festival one day!
Unless you have other ideas!
We're still looking for good ideas
on what to do with this big piece of land.
But, we're gonna go right there!
Which is abit of a place of land we created
where we can relax a bit more.
Just so we aren't alwaysin the middle of Basekamp,
where all the people are and all the noises from the workspace...
So, here, it's much more calm.
It's always a few degrees colder.
Yeah, it's quite a nice place to relax a bit more.
This also has our, I would say, biggest tree on the land?
Iguess it also has the oldest tree
It's an old cork tree.
Most of it burned down, except forthis guy,
because it has a thick bark.
So, it's a bit more fire resilient,
and we put a yoga deckunderneath.
It's a nice place to relax at.
Over here, we have a little tent thatwe built.
You might have seen it a few updates ago.
The goal was to try to make a tent
for staying here for a longer period of time.
It's a bit more of a comfortable tent,
so you can alsostand in there.
It's not always bending forward...
It feels a bit more like a little house!
So, yeah, this is what it looks like now.
There's no one really permanently in here,
but it's used for guests or every now andsome people
Because, we're also still gatheringfeedback and it's really a prototype.
We're trying to improve it!
A few things: the canvas is a bit tight,
the decking on the floor has a few gaps, so insects get in...
So, yeah, it's version one!
We're now considering if we build a new version,
like a completely new tent,or maybe we change this one.
We're not sure yet...
But, now, what we're actually gonna do is the final part!
Which I like a lot!
Maybe the best part.
You've seen it before, ifyou follow these videos!
It's our waterfall, it's our lagoon,
and it's the place which we've cleaned upa lot before.
We can cool down, relax, and take a swim!
Which is particularly nice in thesevery hot days
to get some refreshment!
So, we go right here!
This is also theplace where most
of the people go at the end of the day.
Or, even lunch time, orin the mornings.
They go in chill and take a dip.
So, it's been very good to have it on the land.
We're now also entering the neighbors land,
so it's actually not on our land...
But, the neighbor hasbeen very kind to offer this,
so that we can use it.
It's really nice here as well!
It has much morenative trees growing,
because it has much more water in this part of the land.
It still has mimosas aswell, but yeah...
So, we're almost there!
Right here!
It's also funny, because when we camehere,
there was no pathway here.
But, the more people just go to certain places, pathways show up.
It's a bit like when you have snow,
and yousuddenly see all the traces where people have walked.
You can see what is actually the mostused pathways
from cars or people walking.
So, we have that here as well.
Slowly, the pathwaysrise up.
Yeah, I like that!
But, as you can notice, I'm also just killing some time
to make sure we enterthe lagoon.
You guys can see it over there!
Here, we also have a lot of big old rocks!
It's cool.
No one knows how old is this!
They just say it's very old,
but I would love to know howold it is.
So, if anyone can tell us, let us know!
Here we are!
It's a bitovergrown currently.
We need to maintain it...
But, it grows fast as well!
Everything is wet, and there is a lot of sun.
You can keep on doing this!
We'll do more towards the end of the summer.
As youcan see, the water is also quite low.
So, it is not really 'waterfall', but more of a 'waterdrip'.
But, it's still nice!
And then, we go up here...
Hey Otis!
So, we used to hang out more in the bottom part.
But then, this year, we cleaned up the top part,
where there is a lagoon.
So, this is now where you can take a nice dip and cool down.
The water level used to be until the yellow door.
I'm not sure if you can see that...
So, it's already quite low,
but there's still water inside tocool down.
But, we're not sure if it will be there all summer...
It's the first time we have alagoon, so we're still figuring it out.
Over here, we can relax.
That was kind of it for thisvideo!
In the next video, we're gonna show you
how to make a roof from cans!
Kevin can do that.
- Yes, with these things!
If you already want to see that video,
make sure to support us on Patreon!
You can see the video one week ahead in 4K.
If not, we'll just see you next week here on YouTube!
Okay, that was a long, long walk...
All right! Thanks!
We're gonna take swim now, and we'll see you next video!
Yuuuuup!
- He got it!